one last thing on the Herschel Walker
stuff Herschel Walker appeared on Fox
News he was asked why did your own son
come out against you that was really
damaging to your campaign as many of you
know we covered that Christian Walker a
right-wing influencer who is Herschel
Walker's son denounced Herschel Walker
said he would threaten us he tried to
kill us we had to move six times as a
result of his threats he's a fake he's a
phony all these different things
Christian Walker denouncing his own
father Herschel Walker appearing on Fox
News being asked about it and his answer
is completely incoherent he's doing
tremendous damage to you by coming out
with those statements do you know why
he's saying this
well the damage he's doing is letting
people know that they're left would do
whatever they can to win this seat and I
told you when I got in this race I'm
going to win this seat people see
someone sitting here in front of you
right now that's been redeemed and I
want America to know I'm living proof
that you can make mistakes and get up
and keep going forward but you can only
do it in this country right here and you
can only do it if we get this election
read correct this come November what
What on earth does that have to do with
your son the Democrats his son is a
public Maga right winger his own son has
decided to tell the country my dad sucks
for lack of a better term that has
nothing to do with Democrats and this
absurd rambling answer I have to tell
you on the one hand
this has to be extraordinarily difficult
for Herschel Walker and I empathize with
that to see your son turn against you in
this way but it also has nothing to do
with Democrats what so however but maybe
the saddest thing about it all is many
Republicans who just don't want Raphael
Warnock to be the next senator in
Georgia or to continue being a senator
in Georgia better said since he's the
incumbent
that wild rambling nonsense that we just
heard from Herschel Walker
they'll probably accept it and that's
good enough for them and say Hey listen
he addressed it did he he talked about
Democrats his sons are Maga right-winger
everybody makes mistakes
of different degrees but to not own up
to them and again it's not a mistake to
pay for an abortion if you're coercing a
woman to get one that's a different
story and that may be part of the story
but the mistake of staking out a
completely dishonest public position
that goes against everything that you
have going in your life privately and
then lying about it and then not
admitting that that's what happened it
does show a lack of character and a lack
of conscience and to blame it all on
Democrats who have nothing to do with
your own son turning against you is
really pathetic again I think we have 24
to 48 hours left of this Scandal before
a complete implosion I expect Walker's
campaign to be all but over by Monday
we'll have these clips on our Instagram
find us on Instagram by searching
davidpackman show